une marginalité lorsqu'elle est assumée
revendiquée et on peut la mettre en
valeur et en plus elle devient carrément
une identité
finalement une identité c'est un
habitant taillé à sa mesure
et alors que les gens ils vous rejette
c'est mon grand père qui m'a appelé ça
pour certains membres de la famille des
sommes que lui par exemple qui m'ont
jeté hors de leur maison mais comme une
chienne c'est vraiment arrivé à dakar
un nom qui vous suit la rue à 20h quoi
et alors je me sens mais oui si j'étais
jeune mon père et si c'était ça ma mère
donc la malle gros merde tu seras jamais
cet opus est amer c'est comme ça donc il
faut vivre avec
et alors mon groupe est une chose
magnifique hymne dit tu sais les gens
vous le t'exprimes exclure j'ai dit oui
ils sont obligés de délimiter
c'est quoi ne vient pas dans ma maison
ou longchamp ou ensemble on m'a piqué
mon village où voilà c'est quelque chose
qui est toujours délimité et je fais oui
il dit mais ne sois pas triste
ça vous dit que le reste du monde est
disponible pour toi et donc du coup il
vous apprend presque devenir le mégalo à
l'autonomie il maintiendrait sa petite
maison là où on peut même pas faire un
terrain de football et à l'immensité de
ce monde entier qui m'attend et tout ça
je suis libre via les donc c'est simple
quand on vous interdit de choses
apprenez à conquérir votre propre route
quand on vous interdit aux bateaux
prenez votre modeste barque et un tracé
modifié
[Musique]